hi everyone welcome to borders at the
World Trade Center we are extremely
excited today to welcome mr. Kurt
Vonnegut as well as the producers and
directors and screenwriters all packed
into two people from the new film mother
night which opens in New York on
November 1st and nationwide in November
they're gonna do a short Q&A for us
appear at the podium and then we'll sit
down and sign some books so please join
me in giving them a warm welcome
I'd like to say something is Keith and I
that he directed this movie bobwhite II
wrote it Keith and I were in back to
school with Rodney Dangerfield
and he played Rodney's sons but in order
to get this picture made his piece is an
actor and a director he got into a movie
with Nick Nolte with the sole purpose of
handing Nolte the script for mother
night otherwise the picture would not
have been made I mean it's true is that
sad but true
yeah it's called groveling
yeah well very but he's been a friend
for eight years he must have approached
me eight years ago with the idea of
eventually making it into a movie and
teen years 14:42 14 years and these
things take time and so no of course I'm
receptive and I'm particularly fortunate
in that I'm completely in print and so
anybody wants to see what I did is in
buying this No
the narration is
well I just didn't have the right tone
of voice and and part of the problem is
why I've said everything I have to say
you know I and Melville said that about
whalers his Whalers don't talk anymore
because they said absolutely everything
they could say and asking for another
book for me there will be another one is
is like asking Louie Armstrong to
sentence sing Mack the Knife one more
time if you didn't hear that the
question was about time quake which is a
novel that Kurt just ripped the last
page off the typewriter the other day so
for those of you waiting for the next
Vonnegut I get how long what's the
turnaround how long before something
comes out yes well I that would be nice
if that were the case yeah yeah we had
it we had a show in Denver is a love is
in Denver and yeah we sold 26 pictures
in Denver
it sold two in New York
now there was a a British traders and
they named a Joyce who would who
broadcast for the Nazis he was Lord haha
and he was actually quite funny and he
he was hanged by the British after the
war and I said Jim what if an American
did this if they were an American Lord
haw-haw but what what put me onto this
story in the first place as I was a
cocktail party talking to a guy who had
been a spymaster during the Second World
War
and he said what you're looking for is a
guy who will do as much for the enemy as
he will free you that's the only way he
survives and you hope you get
information from him that you wouldn't
get otherwise but this guy is also the
only way to survive was to help the
enemy and so I said ok let's write not a
spy story for a change I'll toss in
something about he mentioned William
Joyce who was called Lord haw-haw is in
the book mother night Kurt only has one
speech of Howard Campbell's and for the
film we needed three and I actually
pulled from Lord haw-haw speeches during
the Second World War and also from a
terrifying speech of from Joseph
Goebbels called
white why do we hate the Jew or why why
are we enemies of the Jew and put those
words into Nick Nolte's mouth as Howard
Campbell and it's pretty terrifying but
the speeches you hear Nolte deliver for
the most part our actual propaganda
speeches that were made during the war
okay that's it warden um November first
here in New York and in Los Angeles and
then slowly opening across the country
through the rest of the month little on
the 8th of November in Chicago in
Seattle and San Francisco and by the end
of the month poly in all the major
cities in this country and be careful
because by the time we come out I have a
choice of big night Twelfth Night night
watch mother night and the Albert
Brooksville mother so make sure you're
recommending the right film
I get
running screen plan of my name so years
later when the know it I guess
yeah
yeah
if you're not religious I'll make you
religious
the Virgin Mary made it through the
first
well hey try to anything new for me
no I'm burned out case I think you that
this book time quake will come out 15
years now yeah